[Music]  did you guys hear the news  what it's drew's birthday happy  birthday drew happy birthday drew  happy birthday to drew happy birthday  [Music]  sorry uh hour to this show  hey drew it's called your favorite chef  wishing you a very happy birthday from  gordon and oscar lots of love  holy moly only it's your  birthday happy birthday drew peach and i  love you  so much we're your biggest fans and we  just want to say  happy birthday drew you  isn't that right you've been a huge  inspiration  and just a light in my life and i'm so  happy to see you  thriving and killing it and talking to  all my friends on your show  sing to her peach sing to her  happy birthday drew you